last talk of the day we have costas of
scalacas who will tell us about
learning with a few samples
all right thank you very much for the
invitation and thank you everybody for
being here
so this is joint work with my amazing
students uh
yuval dagan nissan tikala and
vardis kanderos
and before i jump into the ising model
itself
i'd like to spend a little bit talking
about the broader
research perspective
and this is motivated by
the common uh operating regime
that we prove learning results for which
is that uh
in which we have uh access to
multiple independent samples from some
distribution of interest
um so very commonly
uh independent observations uh
especially of complex phenomena are
unavailable or very expensive to obtain
because uh commonly we're interested in
phenomena that have a spatial component
or a temporal component or
they're collected on a social network
and as such it's in these types of
scenarios it's hard to get uh
independent observations
right so um there are many
cases where uh uh phenomena we try to
study either in nature or
in social
environments are they involve
observations that are scattered in time
or in space or
on a network and this has been studied a
lot in various fields
[Music]
and here's some reference from the
social sciences studying all sorts of
different
uh human behaviors of their
social networks so in
this type of setting um
when we collect data we encounter
problems of the following type
okay so um so suppose i have a lot of
observations
on students in some college
and each observation comprises a feature
vector x i
and some label y i which could be either
binary or scalar or you know
ternary or whatever for example um
x i could be the feature vector of some
students
and why it could be whether they drink
alcohol or not or how much alcohol
they're
drinking per week
so in this type of setting the question
is the following so
are these observations
n samples from some distribution
or are they one
big sample from some
high dimensional distribution with
dependencies
so i would argue that
it is the latter so for example
if the behaviors of the students are
binary
i would think that
the vector of all the binary behaviors
of all the students
is some could be some distribution that
looks like
what i'm writing here which which has
some whose density has some component
that depends on the individual
features of different students but also
some component that entangles
the behaviors of this
of different students according to some
interaction matrix by which they are
connected
and determined by how strong
uh the peer effects are in this setting
so so this is sort of like a little
example to illustrate
settings where um it's uh more
uh um appropriate to think of
what we the data we have as dependent
observations and not
independent observations of some
phenomenon and the type of
question you would like to ask in these
types of settings
is is it possible to to prove
back learning results like we have been
doing for independent
samples in this type of setting or is it
possible to do parameter estimation
in this type of setting and more broadly
what if anything can we learn
for a high dimensional distribution
given a single sample
from that distribution so so this is the
broader
uh uh
area that uh is motivating uh
today's talk and for some work uh in
this broader area
uh that we have done uh you can check uh
papers by uh you know different subsets
of the authors of this paper
but without further ado let me jump into
the main topic of uh
today's talk which is the izing model
before you do that can i ask you know
yeah you could view those
examples like in an online setting and
you can still get rid of the iid
assumption and you could just hope to
prove regret bounds
um how i mean that also would get rid of
the dependency i mean handle the iid
issue
that's a that's a great question that's
a great comment adam and indeed
sort of like if the data has a temporal
component
this very well fits in the online
learning
viewpoints and indeed uh
some of the interesting works that have
been done
in this uh topic uh
by mori and others look at uh
uh yeah a sort of like temporal data
trying to prove uh uh generalization
bounds
uh so for a social network you know you
would be looking for a way to um
traverse maybe the network in a way that
uh decorates uh
uh things this has been done by london
ital
you know the punchline is that we're
missing a lot of technology to
understand these types of settings
okay uh
cool so yeah i mean so this is very
fertile and uh
uh you know a call to arms is to develop
the right tools to address this type of
setting
uh so jumping into the ising model uh
i hope you've all seen it is a classical
model from
statistical physics which samples
a vector over the boolean hypercube
according to a log density that is
basically quadratic form so maybe the
simplest way to to look at it is
what's written here so the log density
is just a quadratic form
where j is an interaction matrix it's n
by n
and h is a vector of a what are what are
called external
fields so z is whatever you need
so that this is a density um
yeah so uh basically what's happening
here is that
its uh coordinate is plus or minus one
uh the sign and magnitude of this j
i j uh is the local encouragement
of x i and xj to have different or
opposite signs depending on the
magnitude and sine of j i j
and also there is an external field on
every coordinate that also is pushing it
one way or another
but these local encoders can be over
over uh written
by implicit uh by paths
through the underlying network in the
support of
j so it's a complex distribution to
reason about
so it has been proposed as a simple
model to study phase transitions
in spin classes but uh
it's a very natural form uh and
flexibility has uh
given it many applications uh in
statistical physics computer vision
social
network science uh game theory
computational biology and many other
fields
and it's also you know trying to
understand his mathematical properties
have been a
topic of study uh in many fields
include including all these fields that
i just mentioned but also
theoretical computer science probability
theory and machine learning
so uh today's topic is learning ising
models from samples
so the learning problem we will be
interested in is
the following we're given l samples l
independent samples
uh from an isig model with some
underlying
interaction matrix and external fields
maybe we know some constraints uh we
have some constraints on these
and our goal is to estimate these
parameters
um so what types of constraints
would you impose on on these parameters
for for the problem to be
on the tractable side a standard
assumption
um is that
the temperature
which relates to the infinity norm of
this interaction matrix
uh isn't too low so so the this
this thing here is basically the inverse
temperature
of the model so we need an upper bound
on the inverse temperature
that's a standard assumption that has
been made in a
recent work in tcs for learning icing
models
and it's a substantive it's an important
assumption
if
[Music]
you place no assumptions
on the model then it could be that it's
impossible to
meaningfully learn it but let's leave
that for a different discussion
um the non-substantive assumption that i
will make
today is that there is no external field
so
which in particular implies that
[Music]
this distribution is symmetric so if you
flip
the probability of x if you flip all the
signs
it stays identical
so it will make today's presentation
easier but uh what i'm about to describe
extends to when you add uh external
fields as long as you
bound them similarly to bounding the
interaction matrix
all right so with these assumptions so
here's the learning tasks that i'm
interested in
so l samples from an isaac model now i'm
simplifying my notation because the
external field is
gone uh the interaction matrix has this
uh bound on the temperature
and i may potentially add throw in some
other uh constraints
and um uh i'm gonna abstract away these
constraints by
j belonging to some family of
interaction matrices
so my goal today will be to estimate
given these samples to estimate the
interaction matrix
to minimize the frobenius norm of the
network
other other types of guarantees
are also reasonable but i'm gonna
focus on this one today
so what do we know about this learning
problem
as i've mentioned there has been a
renaissance there has been
a long line of research on this topic uh
in machine learning in other fields but
there has also been a renaissance of
algorithms in uh
tcs uh starting this uh
problem and even more general problems
and uh this focus on
uh the case where l is polynomial in the
size of the network
there's also a separate strand of work
in probability theory that targets the
target
single sample estimation of the azimuth
model where l
equals one of course
it's going to be very difficult to learn
a generalizing model when l equals one
so uh this paper is put some assumptions
on
uh the interac some extra assumptions on
the interaction matrix
so let me discuss what these people do
so the multiple sample literature uh
uh places no more assumptions than
that the infinity norm is bounded by n
and in this case the bound of robinus
norm by some
single exponential function of m root n
the size of the network
and log n over the number of samples
that you have to sum
uh to one-fourth
and in particular uh this
type of bound becomes interesting as
soon as l is bigger than log n the
log the number of uh variables uh in the
network uh
as you know as long as you pay this
exponential constant in the beginning
uh and the reason is that um with the
assumption that i've made
the phrabinis norm is bounded by root n
so uh uh the moment l becomes comparable
to log n you start
uh shaving off multiples of root n so
this is this type of bound becomes
interesting
as i've said in the single sample case
we need to make one assumption to prove
something meaningful
and this line of work i'm starting here
has considered this very very very
special case of the problem which is
again i'm placing an upper bound on the
inverse temperature
and also this is a strong assumption
assuming that
[Music]
the matrix the interaction rate is known
up to a scalar
up to an unknown scalar factor
works also place some extra assumptions
about uh the well-behavedness of the log
partition function
around the matrix of the model
and under those assumptions they show
that given a single sample
can estimate the interaction matrix to
within one over
this uh root of the log partition
function
of the model so this is just a
yeah you know if you if you're
interested in just the infinity norm
rather than the forbiddenious norm then
of course we don't need that square root
of n factor up there on the
approximation
i'm not sure why you're interested in
the frabenius norm here instead of just
infinity norm but
uh yeah so uh that's right so the the
way
yeah so the way we get uh this result
from your result
is to exactly use the infinity bound and
uh
multiplied by root n to get the
frobenius bound
i'm interested in the forbidden is bound
because uh uh
in in in the setting that uh uh we'll be
working with it's gonna be
hard to get infinity bound guarantees
okay thanks
so the goal of this work and also sort
of like you know i'm looking to unify
these two lines of work so that our goal
is to
um to unify these two separate strands
of the literature and interpolate
between them for different for varying
values of l
and different settings of this call
graphic
j and we also get want to get
richer results so let's see what we can
do
so all right so uh
the single so our single
result uh this is the main result
everything else is a corollary
is the following so it operates in this
setting where we're given a single
sample
from the isaac model with some unknown j
we place this bound on j and
we assume some family from which this j
is coming from
um so in this setting given a single
sample
what we can show is that
so a lampard statement it looks big but
i'll unpack it
given a single sample there is an
estimator j-hat
it's a function of this single sample
that we got
so that with a probability at least one
minus delta with respect to the choice
the the the sampling of this x from the
true model
uh the estim the estimation error is
bounded by that uh
single exponential that's unavoidable
root some stuff so this stuff is log log
the sum
the size of the network log one over
delta the probability of error
and so this is the important thing so
this is
log of uh
the covering number of this family of
matrices
uh in radius one over n with respect to
the operator norm
which is what i'm writing here
moreover our estimator
is the minimum uh
over this family j cal j
of uh a convex function so in particular
it can be efficiently computed using
gradient distance
if this set is a convex set and you can
project on it
so this is the main result and from this
main result
the only thing i'm going to keep from
now on is
this part so i have dropped this
exponential single exponential
dependence on them which is standard
in this line of work i've also dropped
the log one over delta and the log log n
so i've kept only this better
statement and i want to see some
corollaries of this
statement
so the first coral larry is when j the
candidate networks is a finite class
in this case the bound
is a log the size of the
class
because the covering number trivially
you can choose everything in the class
so you get
just the cardinality of the class
corollary number two is the case where
you have a linear
class so suppose that
the unknown matrix is a linear
combination of
k non matrices
in this case by plugging into this bound
you can get that the error
is root k log n
again i'm reminding you that under my
assumptions
j the frobenius norm of j is up is
could be m root n so this is a
meaningful result it's a non-trivial
result so
uh um if you know
um yeah so it's uh k
root k logan when the maximum of this is
m root n
a third color corollary
sparse linear class so suppose
i'm in the same setting like this
but now uh it's a sparse linear
combination
of k known matrices
so so now what do you expect
s lock key right
so it's uh exactly so it's s root
root s the sparsity log and k
uh okay so fourth corollary i mean these
are just some color layers
that we wrote down here uh fourth
corollary manifold so suppose that uh j
the possible interaction matrices are
the range
as you vary uh some k-dimensional beta
through some ellipsis function that maps
uh this k-dimensional space to r and n
the space of matrices
then uh the error you get is k
log and times the ellipsis
so there are some immediate corollaries
from
the main theorem right
again i'm given a single sample from
this model
and i want to understand what type of
error i can attain
uh estimating the interaction matrix
um given this single sample
and something about the candidate
the the possible uh interaction matrices
that this
model is coming from
what happens if you know that the graph
is a tree or something like that do you
get anything non-trivial then
um
we didn't really study the tree to be
honest yeah
um okay
um
yeah uh we do yeah we haven't really
studied the tree i mean in this
in this paper uh as you know rick price
is going to talk about the paper on
the chili algorithm on wednesday where
the distribution is learned without any
bounds on m
we also have a parallel line of work
doing that but
this is not from a single sample so i
haven't really thought
about trees okay
uh so speaking of l samples of multiple
samples
let's go back to this problem the more
classical problem where
you have l samples from a nice model and
you want to estimate the
matrix j hat
well i claim that the tool that i gave
you can already handle this case
and the reason is that else samples from
any icing model can be viewed as
a one sample
from a tensorized uh ising model with
the same
uh with who's basically
l disjoint copies of this model so l
samples from this model is one sample
from just
l copies of that same model
and because i have a result
for learning from one sample i can just
apply this
result to see what it gives me for l
samples so let's see what it does give
me
what it gives me so here's how the
result changes if i if i if i just take
our main result and apply it uh
by doing this silly uh silly thing
okay of of of calling l samples one
sample from a bigger model
so what you get here is uh something
similar right so
uh there is an estimator j hat that now
takes as input
l samples and uh
uh with probability one minus delta with
respect to those samples
satisfies these bounds uh uh
uh for for for for for frobenius uh
uh learning of j
so the the standard exponential in m
this is log one over delta log log n
that i also had before
but the important thing is that now you
get a boost so your denominator
you get by l the number of samples that
you got
at the small expense and i'll say well
this is small at the small expenses that
now
the covering number that you're looking
for is not
with radius 1 over n but with radius 1
over n times
l so you're looking at the tighter cover
now of the space of matrices
but now you divide the error by root l
now the reason this is good
is that typically the impact of this
factor of l here is logarithmic in l
well this is a root l one over root n so
this is
you know you're gaining by doing this
and the same qualifications applies
before again this is the covering number
with this radius of the interaction
matrices under this norm
this is efficiently computable it's the
minimum of a convex function
over uh this would be n times n times l
uh so it's efficiently computable if uh
uh this set is a i'm sorry it is sorry
it is over this
this is over the variable is interaction
matrices i'm sorry
so it is over rnn and it's efficiently
computable if this set is convex and you
can project on it
efficiently uh
are there any there are some questions
of course it says one question are there
similar one-sample results for structure
learning
uh you mean learning the interac like
learning the support of jay
uh i don't know but i guess that that is
yeah
yeah so learning the support of
j it's gonna be difficult to do
unless you put lower bounds on the
strengths of the edges like
so all previous work from uh multiple
samples
has been putting lower like to recover
the structure they have been putting
lower bounds on the strengths of each
individual edge
and then to satisfy this upper bound
then putting a bound on the degree of
every node
so if you and basically they recover the
structure by
proving stuff like this so you can you
can do this
this thing you can you can convert these
types of bounds maybe
for venues or with infinity norm into
uh structure uh uh results
uh yeah so this is this is how these are
typically obtained and
but we haven't done this calculation but
you can try to do this calculation
and see what you get
um all right so again let's see some
corollaries of this thing
and again i kept the i dropped this
exponential dependence in m
i dropped the log one over delta log log
n
so let's go to consider that you know
you know what happens if i place not
constrained at all on on on j
so j's aren't constrained then what you
get is a forbidden
bound that's n squared logan l
over l so
let's compare that to the
cliven's mecca result so the cleveland's
make a result was root n
the fourth root log n over l
so um what what is the what is the fair
comparison between these
results so this result here
uh kicks in with a non-trivial bound
already when l is
you know comparable like across this log
n
[Music]
so this result for it to give
non-trivial bound
you need l to be above n so this so in
that sense
so for small l this is uh stronger right
so an interesting current team
uh is obtained when l is log n inverse
but here when
l is like n the eventual rate of this is
faster
than this so this is uh fourth i don't
know one
one to the fourth this is one half at
the same time i don't think the
intention of these authors was to
get uh i believe that their intention
was to and they can correct me
their intention was to study the regime
close to logan
and and you know they were doing uh
they were using sparse recovery type of
results and this is
uh how they arrived over here uh
for this bond we didn't really try it's
just followed directly as a corollary of
our single sample result really
and we have not tried to add
regularizers for every neighborhood
to to arrive but sparse type of
guarantees we didn't try it
we didn't try analyzing uh our uh
you know what i'm going to show in a
little bit be our method
with regularization so that's that
explains sort of like why
these results kick in faster than our
results and why the eventual rate that
we get here is faster than that rate
uh but that being said the point of of
this slide is that
you know without any effort from a
single sample result you immediately get
some non-trivial guarantees for
the general case of learning icing
models from multiple samples
moreover you don't need really need to
assume independent samples so you can
get
such similar rates uh
even if you don't have l independent
samples but you have l dependent sample
so
in the paper for example we give one
example where you have sort of like
an inter spatial as well as
intertemporal
uh dependencies between samples so you
get
kind of like different slices so every
slice is a nice
model but all the slices are temporarily
also dependent so and
you can you can still arrive at such uh
types of guarantees so the point the
point of the thing is that
this is a thinking of the problem as a
single sample problem
is a very flexible type of thing that
can accommodate
a single sample multiple independent
samples or multiple dependent samples
and i think there is a lot of room here
to
you know prove you know
uh uh uh you know
such guarantees for mark of random
fields and other types of settings
so just in summary and before i kind of
like give a hint of the proof idea
this is these are our results so
uh the columns are uh you know what we
assume about the family of interaction
matrices
and whether you have one sample or l
samples for some arbitrary l
and you know this summarizes sort of
like the
various classes that i considered finite
class linear combination of
non-matrices parcel linear combination
adding not the
manifold result here and all matrices
uh um also something that i didn't
discuss is that
uh um uh and that is in comparison to
the chatterjee result
and the the pathetaria mukherjee result
that i started earlier
uh in the case where you have a
if you know the interaction matrix up to
a constant factor
our guarantees are stronger than those
that existed in the literature before so
we are
able to remove certain conditions
[Music]
that require the log partition function
to be
well behaved in the neighborhood of the
true model so
um yeah so this is basically summary of
the results
i should also say that we have lower
bounds for general
interaction matrices so we have
essentially a
a lower bound that essentially that you
know that is
uh close to matching but not exactly
of our general upper bound but but if
you apply our lower bound to
finite classes and linear combinations
you get that our upper bounds are tight
for these two cases so our bond is re
for general classes is reasonably tight
albeit not exactly right so this is
basically the summary of the results
and unless there are questions i would
like to give a little overview of the
techniques
okay so they are but you know sort of
like yeah the
the um the um the high level idea here
is that uh
considering the problem as a single
sample learning problem is very flexible
and it can apply to different cases
where you have dependent samples
or you know spatial temporally dependent
samples or even
independent samples although that's not
a
focus of this broader line of work
all right so proof ideas uh
all right so the the the the first
important idea is the following that
so this model here is an exponential
family
uh which you know has some good things
but also uh uh you know
well some nice properties but uh in our
single sample
case uh it's not clear how to use them
anyways
but a natural idea in any event to
learn given a single sample to learn the
interaction matrix
is to try and maximize
the likelihood of the sample
unfortunately that computation
involves the partition function this
denominator here which is in general
interactable to compute so we did not
push you in this work this approach
costa can ask a quick question yeah so
for the families of
easy models that you're considering like
is the
computation of the partition function
intractable for example for the high
temperature regime it's
can be done right correct yeah so
uh it is not yeah so this is not high
temperature
is the problem so this is
m is arbitrary so we don't know that it
is
yeah so it's not uh so
it is known to be interactable for the
models that we try by a result by slime
sun i see that's right thanks yeah so
and the problem is it's not
yeah so it's uh low like you know there
is a yeah
um so uh
what we propose to do is to maximize
what is called the pseudo-likelihood
which was uh
which is a function uh that was
originally proposed
by bessag but has been used
from then in various places so the
pseudo-likelihood
is the product of the conditional
probabilities of the individual
coordinates in the big sample
and the the good thing about this
product which does not correspond
to any you know i mean reasonable
quantity with respect to this measure
but it's just the product of the
marginals
or the conditionals it has an explicit
form so it does not involve the
partition function
and moreover it is it results in a
convex problem
so what bezag proposed is to maximize
this function in the feasible set
which is this and as it turns out
the minus log of this thing is convex
with respect to j
so you can optimize it uh if this
function is number one if you can
project on j
uh you can optimize this function
efficiently
but the pertinent question is is it
consistent is it gonna give you the
right thing
so chatterjee and then bhattacharya and
mukherjee
showed is that the answer is yes
when you know the matrix up to a
constant factor and some extra
properties that are already mentioned
about well-behavedness
of the partition function uh hold
but we're interested in the general case
so what can we say then
so that's the main question so here
again i'm reminding you all the notation
that i'm using so
phi of j and a single sample is the
minus log of the pseudo-likelihood and
this is a convex function
this is the learning problem that i'm
trying to solve and
so the likelihood is this function here
so here's the high level plan of what we
would like
to do um so
suppose j star is the true model that is
giving us the sample
and suppose j prime
is somehow they're far away truth
in throbinus norm what i want to argue
is that when i minimize the minus log to
the likelihood
i'm not going to get this j prime
but i want to i want to argue that the j
that i'm going to get by optimizing this
function
is something close to j star so it
better be that you know if j
prime is far from g star and from venus
uh i'm not going to get it when i
optimize the minus
logs so the likelihood so what i want to
show
is that with high probability with
respect to the randomness of x
from j star that
five value on j prime which is far away
from the star
is bigger bigger than uh uh
the five value on j star itself
which in particular would imply that j
hat cannot be j
prime because j hat must be at least as
good
as j star maybe j star is not the
optimum but j
j hat should be at least as good as that
and if that already beats this other
candidate
then j hat can not be that other guy j
prime
that's that is the plan so
quantitatively here is what we show
that for some pair of constants if j
star is the true model and j hat is some
other candidate
then with some good probability one
minus something that depends on the
distance
of the two models the minus logs of the
likelihood on the prime
is bigger than a j star
but at least the throbbin is norm
squared between the two models
so this is what we show
um and
of course the way i've stated it this
guarantee holds for a fixed
j prime but i want for all j
primes but but going from this bound to
for all
to get a uniform bound that for all j
primes that are far
uh this is gonna hold you there is just
where you use covers
okay so that's not the that's not you
know going from a fixed j prime to all
the primes that are far is not the
core of the arguments the core of the
argument is proving that for a
fixed parameter is far from the truth
this is going to hold with higher
probability
now the main technical challenge is
doing that is that the function
whose values we're interested in
is not just a function of j but it's
also a function of x so what is
x x is a single sample from this i using
model
this sizing model is not in high
temperature so the sizing model is in
lowish like you know the temperature is
lower bounded but
by m so it's not doesn't satisfy the
ablution's condition
so we we have to analyze the properties
of a function
of x
in the low-ish temperature regime
and that is difficult because we don't
know how to prove
concentration not the concentration of
functions of dependent
random variables
um so
pictorially the minus log to the
likelihood is a nice complex function
its optimum is where the greater like
the minimum of this okay so the problem
is constrained but okay for
picture let's say that the minimum is
where it's zero
the true model is not necessarily the
minimizer of this function
so the true model could be somewhere
else
now what i want to argue is that some j
prime that is far from the truth
is certainly not going to be j hat the
minimum
and the way i want to do that
is to look at properties of this
function
and here's what we do study this
function
in the segment that connects the truth
and this alternative model
so this is the segment here at t equals
zero is the star
at equals one is j prime this other
candidate
and uh by um
taylor's theorem or whatever the
intermediate value theorem
the value of this function i'm dropping
x for now
the value of j prime of this fund is the
value of j star
uh the
derivative with respect to t at here
with respect to t
idiot
and half of the second derivative at
summit
time psi
so what we show given this exact
equality
what we show is two things that the
second derivative
is more than four times the absolute of
the first derivative
in the whole interval here
and also so in particular even if this
is negative
it does not is not bigger than the
positive
this is a this is must be positive
because the function is convex
but the question is you know like is the
positivity of this guy
bigger than the possible negativity of
that guy so what we show is that in the
whole interval
uh this is you know it dominates the
possible negative of the sky and also
this guy is bigger than the error that
the
the the lower bound that we wanted to
prove so putting the two together we get
that uh uh certainly these holes
now okay so that's that's
that's a good intention but again as i
was saying earlier
the technical difficulties here are that
these two derivatives that we're
interested in are functions of
x which is a vector of dependent random
variables
moreover as it turns out we cannot
find the function that depends only on
the two these two endpoints j star and g
prime that is sandwiched between
the second derivative and the absolute
value of the first derivative
it's actually uh and that's sort of like
it was a stumbling block in a you know
the previous
line of work as it turns out
we have to identify a data dependent
quantity that we can sandwich
between the two derivatives so you
cannot find an absolute
lower bound on the curvature
that is is bigger also than the uh
gradient you have to find a
data dependent lower bound of the
curvature
that is bigger than the absolute value
of the gradient
uh so this is what we want to do
and um uh so the way we do that
is that to prove this uh
guy the the red one
we argue that the difference of this
from that
concentrates around zero to argue the
purple one
we argue that the difference of this
from that
is positive with high probability
and that is where concentration and
anti-concentration of measure
for functions of x
which are a vector of dependent on the
variable will come into play
so at the end of the day we have to
prove uh
anti-concentration of measure results
new anti-concentration of measure
results for functions
of the ic model in
this regime which is low-wish
temperature and also you know prove a
general
concentration inequality under high
temperature and we have a way to
use this concentration inequality to
also imply the the right concentration
that we want
for the uh low temperature regime that
we're interested in
so this was kind of like an
impressionistic view of the
proof but again the punchline is that
after you frame it as a
single dimensional uh bounding
that involves derivatives and second
derivatives of the
logs the likelihood uh the the the real
challenge
is that bounding these quantities
uh cannot be done first of all uniformly
but you have to have a data dependent
bound
and still uh arguing these inequalities
involves concentration on the
concentration of measure which
you know you know does not exist and we
have to to invent it
so this is basically what i have to say
uh in conclusion again samples from high
dimensional distributions can be scarce
or expensive to acquire and this
motivates this broader line of work
of learning and statistical estimation
from a single sample
what we do in this work is we provide
such an algorithm
for estimating the interaction matrix of
the izing model from a single sample
and we quantify the error with respect
to the metric entropy of
possible interaction matrices in some
family
so this way we unify extend and
interpolate between
two separate lines of work uh dealing
with multiple sample estimation or
single sample estimation we can do
anything in the middle and also get
stronger results in some of these
interpolate regimes um
and and you know on the deeper and
mathematical side
you know you know getting leverage here
requires you to prove concentration and
the concentration of measure
now thank you very much
thank you are there any questions
uh i have a question oh okay they have a
question sorry
uh anna was asking is there is a way to
get
intuition about pseudo likelihood like
is there natural optimization algorithm
which optimizes this objective
so the the natural log i mean
uh yeah so as i said you can do great in
descent
um yeah i mean i haven't really
started you know like try to interpret
what uh uh
what it does uh uh um
uh yeah so it would be interesting to
kind of like look at the iteration and
see if that you know
what they mean but sort of like
intuition about the functional form
itself
uh you can derive so it's not sort of
like a
it's not a horrible idea to do
the likelihood and the rationale for
that is this that
you know remember how uh
you know so let's consider very sparse
like the grid uh and suppose you are
able to find an a large independent set
of uh your graph uh then
writing the likelihood of the nodes in
the independent set
is going to be part of that product of
the of the
of the uh of the pseudolike
so so the conditioning on everybody else
the independent set is not conditionally
independent
uh so the likelihood of the nodes
participating in the
independent set conditioning on the
nodes in the complement of the
independent set
um that the likelihood is a product
measure
and it's part of what goes into the
pseudo likelihood
now in the types of settings that i'm
interested in
i don't have a sparse graph the
independent set is not going to be
necessarily large so uh
the leap of faith is that because
of the assumption on the you know the
lower bound of the temperature
it's not a horrible idea to write down
that product of conditionals and
sort of like the analysis that we do
implies that this is the case of course
as my picture was saying
we're not claiming that the minimum of
that thing is the true model
but we can argue that the true model
isn't too far from the minimum
uh i have another question actually so
uh this is slightly different from what
you were discussing but
um is it an interesting question to say
ask
some property about j like you don't
want to actually infer what j
is but something like is j homogenous is
it basically
all the interaction parameters are the
same or is it very far from such a
matrix
votes yeah yeah so that
that would certainly be interesting um
uh so so i guess you know like i guess
your question applies to either
one sample from the model or multiple
samples from the model
yeah yeah i've been thinking like you're
not doing something faster than learning
like
you just want to know some property of
this using model like the underlying
interaction parameters
not actually learning the parameters per
se yeah
so so this has been pursued although not
as much
so we have a paper with uh nissan
and uh i i have a paper with nissan and
g
uh where the question is for example
you you know you you you're told you're
sampling an ising model
so you know you're you're seeing high
dimensional samples but you're told
these are coming from a nice model
and your goal is to understand whether
it for example is a
it's a product measure okay
that's that's one example uh similar
things have been done by
uh myself and chinchon pond
but also
and daniel kane i believe on bayonets
but generally speaking i do think it's a
very interesting question
both in the single sample regime and the
multi-sample regime
to assume something about the high
dimensional distribution that you are
sampling
and and and you know given that
assumption
uh answer whether it satisfies some
extra property
so so very very interesting and not
pretty pretty fertile as well
so causes one more question but the
broader perspective
are there other learning problems like
you know let's say taking in the
classical pack learning questions or
even something like linear regression
yeah where you have good sort of not
real guarantees
and for this one short learning kind of
thing
yeah so that's that's an excellent
question and we do have um
so going back to this very early example
oops
here so what you're asking is
what happens here if for example this is
a linear model of x i
that would be the
uh
how's my do you see it my second slide
or something else
see it's back learning smart it seems to
be
yeah i see data dependencies like
okay good so so yeah so if i make this
into a linear model
i have the equivalent of the dependent
logistic regression problem
uh right because with beta equals zero
that is logistic regress so
turn this into theta inner product x i
uh
if beta is zero that is logistic
regression
with beta nonzero you
the dependencies between the y the
network dependencies start coming in
so this is the so so
so that would be the the the
classification uh
analog with dependencies you can
similarly have a regression problem
where
again y is theta inner product x i
plus some linear function of the other
y's
or maybe also the otherwise and the
other theta y
x js so so these two problems
we we have studied ourselves and
also have been studied so like
especially the linear case
is called auto regressive autoregressive
model
because why depends not just on excite
but you know
why itself so that that type of
recurrence is called
autoregressive model and it has been
studied
so in uh in a paper with uh nisanti
callan and jan spanayas in
in 2019
we started this problem where we showed
results
uh of estimating feta and beta
when you know a the interaction network
so you know
you know who is friends with whom in the
school and how strong friends they are
but you don't know how strong the peer
effect that you're studying
is and you also don't know the linear
model
that connects the features of the
students to the behavior
so in both linear and
classification problems we have studied
that problem
but uh you know we studied
this case that i told you about but in
general this is wide open so
adding different models here or
different probability models here
uh is wide open in a more
kind of like principled way let's say
like more pack learning
style we also have a paper in cult
last year uh with uh
you know some of the authors of this
paper plus siddhartha
jayanti where we prove a
uniform convergence and generalization
bound
but that one is under the brushes
condition so we we don't like for the
pack learning uh
on the park learning side we haven't
gone beyond the brushing
for this auto regressive models which
are more specific linear and logistic
we have gone beyond uh the brushing
although
we don't have a clear understanding of
all the landscape
okay do you think there's like a general
theory maybe under some conditions and
the correlations between the x i's
you can carry over back learning bounds
to the setting
or would that be yeah like yeah
i i think there should be and in fact
uh if um if you allow yourself
more samples like more independent
multiple independent samples
there is a line of work by london atal
that has proven such generalization
bounds
these are not in the extreme regime that
i'm talking about where you have only
one sample
but if you have say values depend
like many uh many
uh independent samples from a high
dimensional model
and you're trying to learn a function
that maps all the xi's to all the y
eyes for this specif for a specific
sample
there are pac results there as well i i
hope this makes sense
so there is a more developed theory
if you have
uh any independent cells
each of them is
a vector of excise vector ai's so
imagine i have
one sample for school one one sample
from school two
one sample from school n so i have
from mid school i have what all the
students in each school do
there is a pac learning theory developed
by london netal for that type of setting
the setting i'm considering here is more
extreme where i'm only targeting a
specific school
and i want to understand that specific
school
so the theory there is less developed
but i think there is a theory okay
thanks
there's one more question oh sorry
i was going to ask uh because for the
case where you have uh
dependent samples um
what type of dependencies can you allow
any sort of dependencies or
so in the paper we have a result that
um so we prove a general result
that puts some family cal
j on say the spatial dependencies
and some family called j1 on the
temporal intertemporal dependencies
and we prove a general
bound that contains the
um like the
you know entropic numbers with respect
to for both families
sorry like the sum of the log covering
numbers for the two families so we have
we have a general example like that this
is just a correlation of the broader
results so i think
you know you can you can consider your
own setting and you know plug and play
and see and see what you get
based on the single sample result right
so ultimately
whatever structure you assume
uh it should have a you know
decomposable
like uh decomposability property that
will allow you to
you know uh you know
reduce the covering number of the
big model into maybe um some of
our product of covering numbers of
smaller types of networks and you know
plug it into
the um
the single sample result so it's it's
very you can do you know yeah
we have an example in the paper but we
really have not explored that
too much thanks
so there's one more question from anna
do you see any applications to the
problem of causal influence under
interference
uh when and by interference i think she
means
when the treatment in one unit affects
the potential outcomes of
other units oh yeah that is a super
interesting question yeah
i'm very interested in that and sort of
like
to expand a bit on that
indeed when we do experimentation on
networks
you know we you know we we go and treat
some nodes in the network
and we want to understand uh how our
treatments affect
the behavior but of course there are
peer effects that take our treatments
and probably get them throughout the
network
so uh it is important to be able to
disentangle
the effects of our treatments the direct
effects or the second order effects that
are coming out of
uh propagations so so indeed uh
this is a very interesting problem and
uh you know
something that you can use these types
of techniques for
right and just to be clear like just
this model here treating could be
going and changing something on that
particular node x i
right and then seeing what happened like
this
after treating you know five nodes in
this network you get a sample y
of what change in the network did people
stop drinking alcohol
but but you want to disentangle okay why
did that happen how important is the
impact of your intervention on
particular nodes
are there any other questions
well it seems that there aren't any
other questions but
uh thank you costas and thanks to
everybody
all the speakers today so
i guess it's end of the day uh
of course this midnight now uh
and uh so is jesse still here should i
just
like end leave the meeting how does this
end
like yeah yeah we'll turn it off or
we'll turn off the meeting
okay okay great wait i guess the day
resumes tomorrow at nine o'clock
okay thank you